hi everyone I'd like to introduce you to
like her two most of us like her is
simply a very cute pic however to
hundreds of thousands of patient in need
of a life-saving organ like her it's a
symbol of hope you see ever since the
1970s for organ transplants became a
real option for patients with kidney
failure and other organ diseases organ
supply has been an issue over the last
few decades the issue owning worsened as
organ Ament
has exponentially increased currently in
the u.s. they are close to 115 thousand
patients in need of life-saving organ
transplant by the end of my talk one
more patient will be added to this list
today about 100 people will get a new
organ a chance to start their life anew
and yet by the end of today 20 others
will die waiting the situation is
heartbreaking for patients for their
families and for the doctors who want to
do more in some part of the world the
situation also be called a disturbing
social issue in Asia for example media
outlets reported that desperate patients
obtaining organs from the cruel black
market it is clear that a solution is
needed to this crisis human lives are at
stake
as a biologist and a geneticist it has
become my mission to help solve this
problem today I'm optimistic to say that
we are on our way there
thanks to like her using gene editing
technology it's no
the ball to exclusively create human
transplantable organ that can be safely
grown in pigs before we jump into the
incredible science that makes it happen
let's have a better understanding what
xenotransplantation is it's the process
of transplanting animal organs into
humans you may want to ask why pig
organs because some pigs carry organs
with similar size and physiology to
human organs over the last half a
century pioneers of transplantation have
tried hard to make it happen but was
limited to no success why is that two
fundamental hurdles stood in the way
first is a problem of rejection when our
immune system sees a new organ as
foreign it will reject it second and
this wall is specific to the organs from
the pig every Pig carry a virus that has
been my to the pig that can be
transmitted into human it is called the
porcine endogenous retrovirus purse and
this virus has a potential to cause a
viral epidemic similar to HIV without an
effective way to address these issues
the field of Dino transplantation has
been on hold for more than one decade
little progress has been made
until now let me share with you how I
got here today was like her my journey
started from a mountain in China that is
the place we'll described in a lot of
legendary stories like the crunching
Tiger Hidden Dragon that is the place I
call home
growing up in the mountain I started to
have strong connection with nature this
is me while I was seven years old
standing in front of an ancient Buddhist
temple with a monkey on my shoulder
I still vividly remember how my friends
and I would toss the peanuts around to
distract the monkeys so that we can
cross two hikes through the valley I
love nature when it was time to choose
the field of study I chose to study
biology at Peking University in Beijing
however the more I learned the more
question I had how could our genetic
makeup be so similar to animals and yet
we look so different how is our immune
system capable of fighting off so many
pathogens but smart enough not to attack
ourselves cushions like this tormented
me I know it sounds nerdy but you know
I'm a scientist
after college I decided I didn't want to
just ask the questions I wanted to
answer them so I did in 2008 I was lucky
enough to be accepted into the ph.d
program at Harvard University and worked
with dr. George Church while working in
church's lab I started to learn an
experiment the genetic makeup of
mammoths among all the experiment one
particular well took me closer to like
her
in 2013 my colleagues and I made changes
in a human cell using a tool you may
have heard about called CRISPR when we
were one of the first two groups to
report the successful use of such a tool
in changing our DNA
it was exciting moment in scientific
discovery the gene editing tool CRISPR
has two component it has a scissor
called the undying CRISPR and what had
called a guide RNA think about it as a
genetic scissors with a microscope the
microscope is a guide RNA which brings
the scissors to the place were going to
cut and insert here it is in the
unsigned CRISPR just
hot and repair the DLA in the way we
walked shortly after we reported our
study physicians at Mass General
Hospital were intrigued by the medical
applications of our research the reach
out to us and together we began to see
the potential to use CRISPR to solve the
oregon shortage crisis how do we do it
it is simple yet very complex we started
by making changes in a pig salt to make
a virus free and human immune compatible
the new class of that saw is then
implanted into a pig egg and allowed to
divide into a embryo the resulting
embryo is then placed into the uterus of
a surrogate mother and allowed to divide
into a pig basically it's a process of
cooling the piglet then Kari organs
whose genetic makeup hope slave would
have been rejected by the human immune
system in 2015 our team decided to
tackle the burro transmission problem
first we wanted to take out all sixty
two copies of the perv wires from the
pig genome by the time it was nearly
mission impossible even with CRISPR we
could only do one or two modification
with english' the record for number of
modification we can do in a particular
cell was five we had to increase the
throughput by more than ten votes to
achieve that with very careful design
and hundreds of cows we successfully
took out all the virus broke the record
boy importantly our study showed that we
could eliminate the possibility of this
dangerous virus being transmitted into
humans last year with the modified saw
and coding technology our startup a
Genesis produced
like the first pic of its kind born with
out birth like feh represents the first
critical step in establishing the safe
xenotransplantation it is also a
platform that we can do further genetic
modification on to solve the immunology
problem since then we have created more
than 30 pigs without perf and the may be
the most advanced genome modified animal
living on earth when named Laika after
the Soviet Doc who was the first animal
to orbit the Earth we hope like her in
her siblings can lead us into a new
frontier of science and the medicine
imagine a world where patients suffer
from liver failure can be saved with a
new liver without having to wait for a
donation or another human to die imagine
a world where people with diabetes do
not have to rely on insulin after every
meal because we can provide them with
skilled pancreatic cells that can
produce insulin on their own and imagine
a world where patients with kidney
failure do not have to face the burden
of dialysis we are striving to create
the road a road without organ shortage
we finally have the tool to tackle the
problem we could never tackle before and
like her it's just a beginning of our
journey we have to be very humble in
front of the nature because they are
more issue to be addressed including
immunology and things we couldn't even
anticipate at this point however it is
our responsibility to translate the
cutting-edge science into medicine to
save the lives of all
the patients who are waiting thank you
very much
I I mean Luhan this is extraordinary
work here come forward so what's the
next steps here you've got rid of the
virus the next steps involved trying to
get to the point where a human body
won't reject a transplant what's
involved in solving that oh it's a very
complicated process so we need to take
out the integer of the pigs in addition
we can learn a lot from cancer how can
kiss her invade were securement our
immune system so that we can utilize the
trick of cancer and implement that on
the pig organ to fool our immune system
to not attack the organ
when would you estimate when do you hope
that the first successful transplant
would happen it will be irresponsible
for me to give you on any number we read
we're always there responsible but well
working day and night I try to make this
happen for the patients so not even you
won't say that you think it could happen
within a decade or within five years or
something or for sure we're hope it
happened where they weren't decade so
there's a lot of people here who'll be
very very excited that and it's it's
true I mean the potential for this
extraordinary there'll be some other
people here who are going to pick is too
cute you can tweet you know humans
shouldn't be exploiting something so
cute for our benefit do you have any
response to that
yeah sure so I imagine one pic can save
eight people's life in our tuition
similar to human donation if we're only
harvest one kidney from the pig the pig
can steal a life so uh well very mindful
about the issues but I think our goal is
just to address the unmet medical need
for those patients and their families
plus no one can say that to you if they
eat bacon right that's a good point
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]